does that leave the the mask situation
then
well we also set out the uh the details
in terms of masks
we are changing the rules in schools in
terms of the use of masks because we
know that schools
within school wearing a mask in lessons
for instance
uh it means that the lessons are it's
harder to communicate it's harder to
teach
but in in general settings we're keeping
the rules on the mast as they
are for this step outside of schools
um you know master mask wearing is one
of those things that
the the cost of it uh to your personal
sort of
you know going about your normal life is
really really
small we know that they are of benefit
and that's one of the things we've
learned you know one of the things that
scientists have
uh have uh have have developed the
science on and learned during the
pandemic
and so they'll those rules would be
saying the same except for within school
settings
so so the same up until so there's a
possibility at least that
the mask rule the mask mandate if you
like could
could go in june you haven't ruled it
out
well when it comes to when we haven't
ruled that out when it comes to the
the where the where we end up on social
distancing rules
um and the anything to do with
um certification um domestically for
instance
for large events whether that goes ahead
that will all be set out ahead of step
four on monday we're taking step three
and then step four as you know
we've said will happen not before the
21st of june and between now and then
we'll monitor the data and those four
tests that the chief medical officer set
out so clearly
yesterday okay you mentioned
certification
where are we with that because you say
that maybe on the domestic
front that's that's going to come into
play from june but on an international
travel
front that's going to come into play
from next monday
is the app it's meant to be all going on
to the nhs app is that going to be up
and running by next monday
yes the the um certification being able
to show that you've had a
jab is going to be necessary for people
to be able to travel
so we want to make sure people can get
access to that
proof uh not least to show governments
of other countries
that that you've had the job if they
require that
in order to arrive israel is a good
example they've said that they'll want
proof of you having had two jobs
for you to go to to to israel as and
when they
open up they're on the green list of
course so
we will make sure that you can get
access to that to prove that
point that is different to the question
of whether we
require people to be certified as
coveted before before doing things
domestically and
that is something that michael gove is
working on and we're looking at these
pilots that are
that are running uh you saw that there
were you know there was an audience at
the crucible
uh for the snooker finals uh the brits
are going ahead
we're testing different ways that this
might work
for large events and then we'll be
following the science on that
but really the focus for you know for
the time being on this certification
question
is making sure that people can travel
internationally and show that they've
had the jab if that's what another
country requires
i'm sure your people at your end are
telling you that we're almost out of
time i just want to very quickly ask you
about the importance of vaccination
when are we going to move down to the 35
plus age group
yeah pretty soon pretty soon yeah we've
gone down to the
all 40s and above in the last couple of
weeks as you've seen the numbers of
vaccines is going
gangbusters more than 600 000 on
saturday
again and the number of first
vaccinations is actually
rising at the moment and we're getting
through all those
critical second vaccinations really
important if you've got your second jab
then come forward at the time that
you're asked to come forward
that people everybody's doing it it's
absolutely fantastic to see the
proportion of people
almost everybody uh unless they've got
some complicated logistical issue or
it's coming forward for their second job
so important
and we'll let you know as soon as we are
able to take that next step
to the to the under 40s